des oeuvres mouvement narrative des
images animées les créations des ricv
renaissent sont présentés à la
commanderie des templiers
architecte de formation eric vernay se
fascine pour le cinéma depuis son plus
jeune âge ou plus exactement pour la
dimension temporelle mise en images par
le procédé cinématographique reçu déjà
essayé de faire un projecteur qui serait
fait que pour un film en quelque sorte
et puis le projecteur lui-même ce serait
une sculpture et puis le film ferait
partie du projecteur en quelque sorte et
l'ensemble fine projecteurs ce serait
une sculpture à part entière et se
serait fait juste pour ce film là alors
j'ai commencé à réfléchir à cette idée
là et j'en suis venu à faire des
sculptures avec du temps à l'intérieur
c'est à dire des choses qui bougent en
quelque sorte comme au cinéma
parmi ces objets temps pour elle comme
il les appelle se distingue une oeuvre
réalisée en hommage à epicure
philosophes de l'antiquité qui eut
l'intuition géniale des atomes à
l'origine de toute vie organique
il ya donc des petites billes sur un sur
un plateau qui lorsque l'on n'avance
près de l'oeuvre se met en mouvement
elle s'entrechoquent
elles produisent un bruit et en même
temps il ya notre image qui se dessinent
sur l'écran qui est derrière comme si
c'était cette petite ville représentait
donc les atomes constitutifs de ce don
ce don en effet la plupart des
installations cinétique visuel et sonore
dérivés renaissent sont mis en mouvement
par le spectateur ou des logiques auto
générative une exposition originale et
interactive